und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und marietta slomka
guten abend es war ja eine wahrlich
schwere geburt mit viel ärger auf allen
seiten persönlichen enttäuschungen
geschiebe und geschacher vor diesem
hintergrund verwundert es nicht mit
welche strahlen der erleichterung ursula
von der leyen heute das wahlergebnis
aufnahmen das europäische parlament
stimmte mit überraschend großer mehrheit
für ihre 26 kommissare anders als im
sommer als zunächst nur sie selbst als
kommissionspräsidentin zur wahl stand
und das nur sehr knapp schaffte bei dem
ist viel geschehen viele kompromisse
wurden gemacht viele gespräche geführt
das hat offenbar gewirkt anne gellinek
berichtet das also ist sie die von der
leyen kommission diese 27 männer und
frauen sollen europa in den nächsten
fünf jahren verändern schon jetzt
dirigiert von der chefin
wir sehen uns heute abend dann wird
gefeiert 15 minuten zuvor anspannung
weicht erleichterung im plenarsaal was
im juli noch eine zitterpartie war ist
am mittag ein spaziergang
das europäische parlament bestätigt die
neue kommission mit 65 prozent der
stimmen die sozialdemokraten sagen
diesmal ja weil sie jetzt ihren klima
super kommissar franz zimmermanns
bekommen die liberalen stimmen für ihren
digital star margrethe west er die
christdemokraten stellen die meisten
kommissare plus die präsidentin
nach wochen im wartestand kann es also
losgehen
von der leyen kündigt nichts weniger als
einen neustart für europa
unsere union wird in den nächsten fünf
jahren eine veränderung einleiten die
jeden teil unserer gesellschaft und
unserer wirtschaft erfassen wird und
zwar weil es richtig ist in unzähligen
interviews erklärt sie was sie meint die
klimapolitik der sich alles unterordnen
soll der europäische grüne deal das ziel
die eu soll bis zum jahr 2050
klimaneutral werden wie das finanziert
wird sagt von der leyen nicht dass es
teuer wird ahnen alle
das programm ist sehr sehr ambitioniert
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass die
finanzmittel der union zurück gehen
werden wahrscheinlich durch den rexit
und zudem sind auch noch die
zuständigkeiten ziemlich verteilt in der
kommission also wir werden ein auge
darauf haben dass frans timmermans auch
wirklich die mittel zur verfügung
bekommt die er braucht
seit wochen jettet von der leyen durch
die europäische union und versucht die
eu-mitgliedstaaten inklusive deutschland
dazu zu bewegen mehr geld auszugeben für
den künftigen eu haushalt und für den
klima gilt bislang ohne erfolg
und dann wären da noch die sorgenkinder
in der neuen truppe der ungarische
kommissar ist ein mann von euro-bonds
gnaden dass ausgerechnet er über
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit in
beitrittsländern wachen soll
ist zumindest fragwürdig in der kritik
auch der franzose thierry breton war bis
vor kurzem chef eines digital
unternehmens jetzt soll er die regeln
für diesen industriezweig machen was
eigentlich noch nie gegeben hat ist dass
jemand von der spitze eines großen teil
nimmt direkt auf die zuständige
kommissar position gekommen ist und dann
in zukunft die zukunft regeln soll über
gesetze die sein eigenes unternehmen
betreffen
das also ist auch die neue von der neuen
kommission gewählt bestätigt und ab
sonntag offiziell im amt und die eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen hast uns haus straßburg
zugeschaltet guten antwort von der leyen
guten namen frau slomka sie können nun
endlich mit verzögerung loslegen aber
sie wissen natürlich auch dass ihre
berufung quasi von außen durch
hinterzimmer auch führungen und
verletzungen ausgelöst hat wie werden
sie damit umgehen das ist richtig wir
hatten einen schwierigen start zusammen
vor fünf monaten aber ich habe diese
zeit genutzt um mit allen politischen
gruppen mit den abgeordneten aber auch
mit den mitgliedstaaten so viel wie
möglich zu sprechen über das gemeinsame
programm
und ich finde die tatsache dass wir
heute 65 prozent bekommen haben in
diesem parlament ist ein gewaltiger
vertrauensvorschuss der auch zeigt dass
das parlament entschlossen ist die
gemeinsame europäische agenda nach vorne
zu bringen und das ist ein guter
startpunkt wurde zugestimmt weil da auch
jeder was bekommen hat das ist ja auch
so üblich trotzdem stellt sich immer die
frage die unabhängig eine kommission ist
also in ihrer neuen kommission wird ein
italienischer kommissar für die
einhaltung der stabilitätskriterien
zuständig sein ein ungarischer kommissar
für die einhaltung von rechtsstaats
prinzipien bei eu-erweiterung skan die
daten wird dann nicht der bock zum
gärtner gemacht
das ist das schöne an der europäischen
kommission in dem moment wo die
kommissarinnen und kommissare bestätigt
sind und wir heute diese wahl auch dann
gehabt haben sind sie ausschließlich der
europäischen gemeinsamen sache
verpflichtet
es geht um die europäischen verträge die
sie einhalten müssen mit mir zusammen
wir sind die hüterin der verträge und
wir werden als kolleg gemeinsam einen
eid darauf schwören das heißt ich werde
sehr genau darauf achten dass wir
ausschließlich im sinne europas handeln
und entscheidend werden und das keiner
und keine von uns abgesandte des eigenen
mitgliedsstaates sind dass es etwas
darauf sind alle eingeschworen und ich
bin sicher darauf werden sie daran
werden sie sich auch halten
man hat ihr kollege franz zimmermann es
die erfahrung machen müssen dass er
nicht eu kommissionspräsident wurde
unter anderem weil er so auf die
rechtsstaats prinzipien gebracht hat ist
das nicht auch ein schlechtes beispiel
dass das schule gemacht hat gerade was
das thema rechtsstaat angeht das ist die
grundlage unserer gemeinsamen
europäischen union das ist das auch was
die europäische union stark gemacht hat
dass man sich darauf verlassen kann dass
der rechtsstaat funktioniert das heißt
dort wird es keine kompromisse geben wir
haben sogar gemeinsam besprochen dass
wir eine verfahren ein monitoring
einführen werden für alle
mitgliedstaaten so dass alle jedes jahr
auch berichten wie weit sie sind bei dem
thema rechtsstaatlichkeit und wo die
schwierigkeiten aus sind damit klar ist
es geht uns alle an und das ist eine der
grundlagen der schätze der europäischen
union die wir pflegen müssen erhalten
müssen und immer wieder nach vorne
bringen müssen und haben sie zu einem
ihrer wichtigsten thema den sogenannten
green deal erklärt also eine ehrgeizige
klimaschutzziele
das wird investitionen das wird
innovationen verlangen das kostet auch
geld woher soll das dann kommen wenn die
mitgliedstaaten sich noch nicht mal
richtig einigen können
das eu budget zu erhöhen
ja der european green deal ist
entscheidend mit dem thema
digitalisierung das sind die beiden top
themen die wir haben wir alle wissen
dass der kampf gegen den klimawandel
keinen aufschub mehr erträgt dass wir
handeln müssen und es ist richtig dass
wir auf europäischer ebene zeigen dass
wir vorangehen können wir sind im
augenblick vorbild weltweit
und wenn wir es richtig machen wenn es
uns gelingt zu zeigen dass man umwelt
schonende freundliche technologien
entwickeln kann dass man grüne
finanzierung anwenden kann und dabei
auch den wohlstand erhöhen kann
wenn wir es schaffen zu zeigen dass man
das ganze fair und sozial machen kann
das heißt die menschen mitnehmen kann
wenn uns das gelingt dann werden wir
vorreiter seien auch magazin wir werden
die exporteure von wissen seien was sich
als zukunftsvision aber von der leyen
aber es muss ja auch mal ganz nah das
programm das wir entwickelt haben und
man sieht es daran dass zb beim
zertifikatehandel den wir aus
deutschland auch canon china jetzt kommt
zur europäischen kommission um zu lernen
was wir richtig gemacht haben und welche
fehler sie vermeiden sollen sie sprachen
zu recht von den finanzen
wir werden sowohl eigene europäische
mittel als auch die beiträge der
mitgliedstaaten haben wir werden
öffentliches geld finde ich das so
nennen darf aber wir werden auch
privates geld brauchen die europäische
investitionsbank hat sehr klar sich dazu
verpflichtet zur europäischen klima bank
zu werden also damit auch das hebeln der
finanzen und das einwerben der privaten
seite zu unterstützt von 23 personen hat
unser lehre ambitioniert wir sprechen
von einer billion die wir auf den weg
bringen müssen in der nächsten dekade
das ist machbar das ist sehr
ambitioniert gar keine frage aber ich
glaube unser planet ist es wert und es
ist eine riesen chance für europa
vorreiter und trendsetter zu sein sagt
die in neuer eu kommissionspräsident in
danken frau von der leyen
danke ihnen frau sonntag
das interview haben wir aus
termingründen am frühen abend
aufgezeichnet eine kurzvorstellung des
kompletten teams der neuen eu kommission
finden sie auf heute.de
derweil war heute in berlin
generaldebatte im bundestag gelegenheit
zum rundumschlag für die
oppositionsparteien gelegenheit aber
auch zur umfassenden selbsterklärung für
die bundeskanzlerin angela merkel sprach
dabei heute nicht nur generell zu plenum
und fernsehzuschauern
sie sprach insbesondere auch zu allen
spd mitgliedern im land schließlich wird
die spd an diesem samstag entscheiden
welches du künftig die partei führen
soll und damit auch wohin die partei
geführt wird
raus aus der großen koalition oder nicht
die bundeskanzlerin ließ keinen zweifel
daran welche meinung sie dazu hat
patrick wiedemeyer berichtet es mag
zufall sein es mag absicht sein
irgendwie stand alles heute im zeichen
von schwarz-rot spd und union allen
voran die kanzlerin beschworen die gute
arbeit in der koalition und merkel ließ
keinen zweifel daran
sie will weitermachen wir haben viel zu
tun haben sehr viel angefangen aber
vieles muss noch weiter gemacht werden
deshalb finde ich wir sollten die
legislaturperiode lang weiter arbeiten
meine persönliche meinung
ich bin dabei herzlichen dank die
kanzlerin verteidigte zuvor in ihrer
rede die politik der gruppe und die
einhaltung der schwarzen null
sie lobte die nato versprach höhere
verteidigungsausgaben sprach vor allem
über die außenpolitik weitere
herausforderungen seien jetzt
digitalisierung und kampf gegen den
klimawandel der land wie deutschland ein
prozent der weltbevölkerung stellt und
zwei prozent der co2 emissionen
verursachen und über die besten
technologien verfügt wer wenn nicht wir
wollen zeigen dass es geht dass man den
klimawandel etwas entgegensetzen haben
einsamen auch der spd-fraktionschef
verteidigte die leistungen seiner partei
in der koalition beispiel grundrente in
der sicherheitspolitik ging allerdings
auf distanz zur union
sie wollen dass die bundeswehr im
indopazifik an der seite australiens
neuseelands japan die volksrepublik
china militärisch eindämmt welche hybris
ist dass wir wollen nicht als
sozialdemokratische bundestagsfraktionen
dieses streben nach militärischer
dominanz mitgehen sondern wir wollen
eine dominanz in der diplomatie heftige
kritik von der opposition schwarz rot
stehe für tatenlosigkeit beim
klimaschutz zu wenig um den drohenden
abschwung zu verhindern
ich kann nur sagen wer die wirtschaft
links liegen lässt darf sich über
probleme von rechts irgendwann nicht
wundern spielabbruch und neue
mannschaften während das beste weil sie
sich nicht mehr mit den
herausforderungen deutschland und in
europa geschäft sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin ich gebe ihnen ja
absolut recht dass die rolle der
bundesrepublik deutschland eines
hochtechnologie landes zur bekämpfung
der klimakrise sein sollte genau zu
zeigen wie es geht
er stellt sich halt bloß die frage warum
machen sie das denn nicht für die afg
sind alle geplanten klimaschutzmaßnahmen
unsinnig die regierung setze damit die
energieversorgung deutschlands aufs
spiel ein blackout sei wahrscheinlicher
als eine klimakrise
was passiert wenn sogenannte
klimaaktivisten ist tatsächlich schaffen
ein großes kohlekraftwerk lahmzulegen
haben sie sich einmal ausgemalt was ein
tagelanger black aus bedeuten würde
denken sie doch nur an die abertausenden
menschen die ihn fahrstühlen
eingeschlossen werden
die kanzlerin und die cdu
parteivorsitzende sie beide zeigten sich
von der kritik unbeeindruckt dass sie
weiterhin auf schwarz-rot setzen daran
diesen sie heute zumindest kein zweifel
das internet vergisst nicht bei dummen
posts oder peinlichen fotos die man
selbst veröffentlicht hat ist das für
viele schon schlimm genug doch das
problem hat auch noch eine juristische
dimension und damit beginnt die
nachrichten vom belag aus es gibt ein
recht auf vergessen in zeiten des
internets das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht betont damit
können zeitungsverlage verpflichtet
werden weil lang zurückliegenden
straftaten namen der täter in ihren
archiven nicht mehr frei abrufbar zu
machen
ein vor 37 jahren wegen mordes
verurteilter mann hatte
verfassungsbeschwerde gegen ein urteil
des bundesgerichtshofes eingelegt mit
erfolg wenn betroffene die löschung
ihrer namen verlangen müssen verlage die
nachkommen und dabei pressefreiheit
gegen persönlichkeitsrechte abwägen über
bessere maßnahmen im kampf gegen
rechtsextreme hass kommentare im
internet wird auf der herbsttagung des
bundeskriminalamtes beraten
bka-präsident münch kündigte deutlich
mehr personal bei polizei und
kriminalamt dann an rechten hetzern im
internet solle das leben schwerer
gemacht werden um damit
rechtsextremistische straftaten zu
verhindern
zudem will der bund das strafgesetzbuch
um regelungen zur hasskriminalität
ergänzen
der bundesgerichtshof hat in einem
grundsatzurteil angebote von internet
dienstleistern auch zur durchsetzung von
mieterrechten als zulässig erklärt
sogenannte liegl tech portale wie zb
weniger miete de seien rechtmäßig obwohl
sie keine rechtsanwalts lizenz haben und
verbraucherrechte nur als
inkassounternehmen durchsetzen
dabei bearbeiten softwareprogramme
streitfälle um schönheitsreparaturen
oder zur durchsetzung niedrigere mieten
zahlen müssen kunden nur bei erfolg die
bundeswehr nimmt einen neuen marine
hubschrauber von airbus vorerst nicht in
betrieb
grund sind erhebliche lücken in der
bedienungsanleitung die einen sicheren
flugbetrieb nicht erlaubten heißt es aus
dem verteidigungsministerium
airbus helikopters hatte im oktober
einen ersten hubschrauber nh90 see leyen
an die bundeswehr übergeben bis 2022
sollen 18 bestellte maschinen dieses
typs in betrieb genommen werden
in albanien ist die zahl der todesopfer
nach dem erdbeben auf mindestens 27
gestiegen etwa 650 menschen wurden
verletzt
allerdings gelang es den helfern auch 46
überlebende aus den trümmern zu befreien
die rettungsarbeiten gehen tag und nacht
weiter inzwischen sind auch immer mehr
internationale hilfsteams eingetroffen
sie helfen bei der bergung und versorgen
die menschen mit proviant und
notunterkünften
häufiges schwere erdbeben ständige
überschwemmungen und eine marode
infrastruktur haben in indonesien zu
einer radikalen entscheidung geführt
der größte inselstaat der welt mit fast
zwei millionen quadratkilometern fläche
auf 17.000 inseln hat beschlossen seine
hauptstadt jakarta zu verlegen komplett
woanders hin
nach 500 jahren stadtgeschichte sollen
sich die riesen metropole und ihrer
einwohner ganz neu erfinden
in zukunft wird es solche umsiedlungen
weltweit wohl immer öfter geben wegen
des klimawandels vor allem inselstaaten
bekommen angesichts steigender
meeresspiegel immer mehr probleme
wenn häuser ständig unter wasser stehen
bleibt am ende nur ein umzug eine ganze
hauptstadt zu verlegen
das ist allerdings ein besonderer
kraftakt und mit gewaltigen
nebenwirkungen normen odenthal berichtet
tage an denen die sonne nicht aufzugehen
scheint davon gibt es viele in jakarta
tage an denen die luft so unerträglich
ist ob von diesen tagen gibt es viele in
jakarta tage an denen die straßen aus
allen nähten platzen jeder tag ist so in
jakarta aber das größte problem ist ein
anderes
jakarta droht der untergang die reste
der moschee sind noch da noch viele
andere häuser im norden jakartas sind
schon versunken das wasser holt sich die
stadt die leute ziehen dahin wo es höher
ist an höher gelegene plätze sie wollen
nicht überflutet werden
ich schätze dass ich auch bald hier weg
muss immer höher bauen sie die mauern
die schützen sollen
der klimawandel lässt den meeresspiegel
steigen aber schlimmer das land versinkt
um bis zu 25 zentimeter jedes jahr zwei
meter fünfzig in zehn jahren nur knapp
die hälfte aller haushalte ist an die
wasserversorgung angeschlossen die
anderen punkten grundwasser versorgen
sich selbst damit
deshalb sinkt der boden deshalb läuft ja
karte ab sinnbild einer hauptstadt deren
probleme zu groß werden wir können nicht
mehr alle last auf kaka legen diese last
ist zu groß da ist die
bevölkerungsdichte die staus die
luftverschmutzung und dann das große
problem mit dem wasser wir müssen
unverzüglich handeln handeln heißt
umziehen auf die insel borneo hier soll
eine neue hauptstadt aus dem boden
gestampft werden was kommt auf die
provinz zu
und wenn regierung und behörden gehen
was wird aus jakarta und seinen
einwohnern
solche fragen scheinen fast
nebensächlich
es geht um das vermächtnis des
präsidenten planung finanzierung
umsetzung das alles ist schlecht
vorbereitet es ist ein wettlauf gegen
die zeit
2024 endet diese präsidentschaft bis
dahin soll der umzug beginnen
indonesiens neue kapitale an einem ort
der bisher dem regenwald und seinen
orang utans gehörte 33 milliarden dollar
soll der umzug der hauptstadt kosten am
ende könnte der preis viel höher sein
in den planungen ist von einer grünen
stadt die rede aber was genau heißt dass
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt können wir nur
hoffen dass auf den wald und die tiere
rücksicht genommen wird
aber wenn diese stadtentwicklung unter
solchem zeitdruck geschieht ist das kaum
vorstellbar einen namen für die neue
hauptstadt gibt es noch nicht aber die
vision dass ihr 1,5 millionen menschen
ihr zuhause finden so hat jakarta auch
mal angefangen heute leben dort 30
millionen
und jetzt nochmal wunderwerks abmeldung
was der deutschen wirtschaft die
veränderungen in der automobilbranche
führen zu sparprogrammen bei allen
konzernen nach audi hat nun auch bmw
seine pläne konkretisiert und will dabei
aber weitgehend auf jobabbau verzichten
sina mainitz was kommt auf die
bmw-mitarbeiter zu künftig soll vor
allem bei den zeitarbeitern gespart
werden weniger hart trifft es die
stammbelegschaft aber auch hier müssen
sich die arbeitnehmer auf kürzungen
einstellen
vor allem in der verwaltung es
verringern sich die erfolgsprämien der
stamm mitarbeiter das weihnachtsgeld
wird teilweise gekürzt für alle wird es
an der 35 stunden woche bemessen auch
wenn sie mehr arbeiten
die betriebliche altersvorsorge soll
gedeckelt werden und ist demnächst
abhängig von der dividende das heißt
weniger dividende weniger betriebliche
altersvorsorge nichts bekannt ist bisher
über die kürzungen beim bmw vorstand ihm
wirft man vor den wandel der
automobilindustrie verschlafen zu haben
neue mobilität kostet zunächst einmal
arbeitsplätze und trifft auf unmut bei
herstellern und zulieferern auch der
diesel skandal rückte die autobranche in
ein
schlechtes licht vorbei die zeiten in
denen sich politik und autoindustrie
gegenseitig sehr wohlgesonnen waren
nun soll es eine neue richten hildegard
müller
sie wird offenbar die neue des mächtigen
verbandes der automobilindustrie eine
frau an der spitze der von männern
dominierten autolobby soll das image der
branche aufpolieren und bernhard mattes
beerben
hildegard müller war staatsministerin im
bundeskanzleramt sie hat acht jahre lang
den verband der energie wirtschaft
geleitet und war im vorstand bei rwe
innogy tätig damit hat die 52-jährige
die energiewende mit vorangetrieben und
soll nun den wandel in der autobranche
begleiten
der wichtigste deutsche industriezweig
sortiert sich neu vielen dank wiener
nach erfurt
besonders große rentenlücken drohen in
deutschland selbständigen
geringverdienern und frauen das geht aus
dem aktuellen renten bericht der
organisation für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung hervor
demnach ist das alterseinkommen von
frauen hierzulande um 46 prozent
niedriger als das der männer womit
deutschland im oecd vergleich am
schlechtesten abschneidet gründe seien
dass insbesondere in deutschland viele
frauen teilzeit arbeiteten sowie die
weiterhin bestehenden lohnunterschiede
eine unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes gibt es in dieser nacht
wird ist im nördlichen harz bei
wernigerode heftig stürmen orkanböen
könnten schäden anrichten und jetzt
haben wir die gewinnzahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten diesmal wie immer
ohne gewähr
112 20 33 40 41 superzahl 9 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text
der deutsche zukunftspreis geht in
diesem jahr an das münchner unternehmen
cellonis die wissenschaft auszeichnung
überreichte am abend bundespräsident
steinmeier in berlin
der preis ist mit 250.000 euro dotiert
und würdigt die innovationsleistung
sowie das arbeitsplatz potenziale
projekte cellonis ist ein daten
spezialist verbessert die prozessabläufe
in unternehmen und hat in 8
jahren einen marktwert von fast 2,3
milliarden euro erreicht das zdf zeigt
die ganze preisverleihung gleich im
anschluss an das heute journal
und noch ein blick in die zukunft für
berlins herta gab es heute große
neuigkeiten jürgen klinsmann kommt das
ist nur eine echte überraschung
das ist ein trainerwechsel geben würde
war klar so spätestens nach dem debakel
gegen augsburg letzten sonntag aber
klinsmann hatten die meisten wohl nicht
auf dem zettel
hertha fans dachten er an denen gerade
vom fc bayern beschafften kovac nun
bekommen sie einen anderen ex bayern
münchen trainer außer dem
ex-bundestrainer und ex weltmeister da
schien heute fast ein hauch von
sommermärchen durchs november graue
berlin andreas hegg berichtet er ist
gekommen um einen schlafenden riesen zu
wecken
hertha bsc ambitioniert und mit übrigen
investoren millionen in die saison
gestartet steht nur auf platz 15 der
tabelle
jürgen klinsmann will das umgehend
ändern das allerwichtigste es aufgrund
der jetzigen konstellation ist nach oben
zu klettern aber so schnell wie möglich
und dann wenn man mal hoffentlich dann
im gesicherten mittelfeld später ist
dann geht's auch da wiederum nach oben
zu blicken
geldgeber las windthorst unternehmer aus
der investmentbranche hatte vor drei
wochen seine anteile beim hauptstadtclub
auf 49,9 prozent aufgestockt nun schon
insgesamt 225 millionen in den klub
gesteckt und klinsmann als seinen
berater im aufsichtsrat platziert seit
15 jahren ist klinsmann mitglied bei den
berlinern nicht der einzige bezug zur
hat eine lange vorgeschichte auf meinen
vater der bei begeistert davon war mein
erstes bundesligaspiel war stuttgart
gegen hertha da stand ich hin da ist
achtjähriger bub in der kurve mit einer
blau weißen fahne und mein sohn durfte
hier zwei lehrjahre machen klinsmann
bringt einen imposanten trainerstab mit
ein co-trainer wird alexander nouri
früher chefcoach bei werder bremen und
andreas köpke den klinsmann einst als
torwarttrainer der nationalmannschaft
installiert hatte wird bis zur
winterpause vom vfb ausgeliehen
er gehörte wie joachim löw zum
trainerteam mit dem klinsmann das
sommermärchen 2006 bei der heim-wm
schrieb damals ein gefeierter dritter
platz 2008 die erste trainerstation bei
einem verein der fc bayern münchen den
klinsmann umkrempeln wollte leseecken
und yoga zu wenig bayerische folklore zu
wenig erfolg nach nicht einmal einer
saison war schluss zum symbol der
missglückten bayern ära klinsmann wurden
buddha figuren
ich habe den installiert ja die haben
also die haben mit mir nie etwas zu tun
gehabt fünf jahre bei klinsmann dann
nationaltrainer der usa bei der wm 2014
erreichte er mit ihnen das achtelfinale
aus kalifornien ist der weltmeister von
1990 nun zumindest bis ende der saison
zurück in deutschland gelingt ihm am
samstag gegen dortmund mit dessen
angezählten coach 1 erfolg beim
bundesliga-comeback dann steht mit
lucien favre
der nächste trainer im regen ja so viel
von uns gleich das wetter und dann wie
schon angekündigt der zukunftspreis und
nachrichten gibt es dann wieder um 0.45
gehen heute bloß mit daniel brack auf
und ist morgen wieder bis dahin
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter tiefer luftdruck
bestimmt unser wetter in deutschland
dieses tief hier wandert von der nordsee
allmählich zur ostsee und dabei kommen
wieder neue regenwolken ins land zu säen
blau eingefärbt auf der alpensüdseite
kündigt sich neuer schnee an
ja und bis zum wochenende wird es kälter
von norden kommt die kalte luft bis nach
deutschland und so steigen die
temperaturen teilweise nur noch knapp
über die null-grad-marke dazu gleich
mehr wir schauen erst einmal in die
nacht da gibt es viele wolken im westen
es regnet kräftig unter wind schlägt zu
es kann zu sturmböen kommen mit werten
um 75 kilometer pro stunde im osten
bleibt es überwiegend trocken die
temperaturen dazu liegen bei 2 grad im
südosten deutschlands und 10 grad zum
beispiel am niederrhein morgen im
tagesverlauf also ziemlich dicht bewölkt
und viel regen vor allem im westen
deutschlands nach osten da kann mal die
sonne durch blinzeln aber die meiste
zeit bleibt es dicht bewölkt und auch
wendig temperaturen erreichen an der
neiße maximal 13 grad am alpenrand sind
es sieben grad
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage da
gibt es recht viel regen noch am freitag
vor allem im süden deutschlands im
westen da zeigt sich schon mal die sonne
windig bleibt es noch fünf bis zehn grad
und schauen wir auf die nächsten tage
am samstag deutlich kühler in den
mittelgebirgen durchaus schneeflocken
dabei zwei bis acht grad und sonntag
noch kälter 0 bis 6 grad
damit ein schöner abend